oh how would you rate my oral skills out
of ten
he's gonna give her in like an eight
that's my guess
probably gonna eat
we're going to do a video from the cut
today you know keep switching it up my
name is vida
i'm ryan my name is madison my name is
michaela
mikayla and i were best friends in ninth
grade then we dated the same guy and
then we fell out of touch for like
10 years before i slid in her dms yeah
and now we're here
i moved here from nebraska for a job and
then we met shortly after i moved
because we worked together there was a
time where i wanted to be in a
relationship with ryan
but just didn't work out that way so i
tried to move on
but here we are you still want to be in
a relationship with him
the amount of sadness that you said that
with was impressive
maybe unspoken rules i feel like when i
stop texting michaela back she knows not
to text me back
and ladies this is why sudden hits do
not work
subtle hints do not and i repeat
do not that was rough to listen to
that's rough
the giant and her face the jaw drop on
this one i mean even if it's true don't
say it in front of everybody
yeah in front of everyone like that's
everybody yo that's like you just said
to everyone yo
that was clingy are you friends with
benefits
yeah what does that mean so we don't
hang out in public very much
most the time we hang out it's
horizontal i like that
they have that same relationship with
each other that i have with white women
bro hello when i said that joke last
time
in the comments yeah they got mad they
got superman listen whenever we go out
without white people
i don't go out with white girls
i mean not in public
i just think it's it's it's a proper
form of reparations what you guys did to
us in slavery
we're doing back to you in modern times
the [ __ ] you know what i mean
right that's helping yeah you know what
i mean an eye for an eye
it makes the whole world go ugh
i don't know what am i doing people
people actually think that you're
serious when you say that no no my first
girlfriend was white my last
oh how would you rate my oral skills out
of ten
he's gonna give her in like an eight
that's my guess but if you don't don't
say ten
don't lie
probably gonna eat
you know what because you know how i
[ __ ] yo i'm so good at this you know
you know the thing here
don't even talk to me you don't talk
that's it
[ __ ] if you don't get the [ __ ] out of
here oh
jesus christ this guy's so excited about
guessing how much you're going to get on
oral
i just knew i'm a genius
this guy man yo listen
if you don't like and comment right now
i'ma fight you
oh man well i guess the magic number is
eight all the time you know what i mean
but seven he was not yet he was not
about to give her a ten
not after how long it took for him to
answer here's the thing
right here's the thing men are kind so
we won't say anything below a five even
though you may be below a five
a lot of y'all give one out of ten some
y'all give a negative
or use your teeth and it's unacceptable
here
now when a dude's gonna rate a girl she
still wants her to know that she's not
perfect but he's gonna say something
reasonable so you're right
you're right there's only like four
numbers that are available it's between
six and ten
that's it and six is actually the
meanest as you're gonna be yeah except
if we're gonna go out out of spite yeah
the only way that he would give you a
five or anything lower and that you
would accept it is just like you bit off
a piece of his penis
and you like remember that one time you
should be like oh that's true i'm sorry
and you would still give her a five even
though she should be at negative ten
yeah
but anyways i feel like it should be
higher wow
okay i feel like it should be higher i'd
be like why don't you work for it
because i can assure you if you was at
10 we would let you know
be when i meet a ted and see good
she don't even need to ask me she just
see my wife why did you see my turtles
this is what i say it feels like you're
being hit by a tsunami you know what i'm
saying
like tsunami alert and you start holding
on for
the brace for impact that is glorious
why you just you
oh my god am i peeing i don't even know
it feels great all this to say
am i did you say am i peeing the first
time it happened i thought it was
because i didn't know how sad would you
be if we never had this again
pretty sad i'd probably have to like
start having some dudes again
sounds horrible yeah kinda would you
have a three-way with me
yeah absolutely do that again again
we have a really great friend shout out
susie susie
susie's not even on the show when she
got out who who's it
like there was a set it's hard to do a
gangster side with the name suzy yeah
it's really hard yeah bubbles yo bubbles
cheat
bubble street [ __ ]
yeah come through my hood [ __ ] watch me
blow these bubbles at you
yeah watch them go pop pop pop pop
does it hurt your feelings when i sleep
with people that aren't you no
okay does it hurt your feelings when i
sleep with people that aren't you i'm
not actively happy about it but it
doesn't i don't ask her about it and
i'll really
see i didn't actually know that you like
didn't want to hear about it necessarily
are you saving other people yeah okay
yeah
okay yeah it's happening good for her
hey man you should be able to exercise
live your life if it's open like that it
is open do your thing
yeah but don't be going like damn like
your bj's are
eight but hers are don't be enough are
you guys a lot of sleep
does it hurt your feelings when i sleep
with people that aren't you
i'm not hooking up with anyone else she
knows that
madison
there's something about that smile
an untold story maybe but there's
something about that smile
i don't know is it jealousy
there's something about that smile
there's something about that smile it's
a
if yeah i don't know when you couple
that with the other answer which is like
i just not respond and she knows you can
just tell that she's getting something
she knows that
you know that right you know that you
know you know you know that yeah
yeah you guys are friends with benefits
but she just has more benefits than you
no i'm not at the moment i don't know
you want me to like
keep a production schedule of my
nighttime activities maybe madison
she almost got outed right there she did
a slick one way
but no way do you know what it is we go
have a conversation later
i want to see who you benefited with on
the count of three
name who likes who more who do you think
who likes who more yeah she likes him
more he likes her more
in the relationship
[Music]
i agree that's okay though
you were right on the count of three
name who likes
who more in this relationship the girl
in the blue is obviously the one
like we're not even one two three
michaela you
oh my god wow
can i rip this one off no can i rip this
one up
but it's true but you don't come with
arguments
oh my god she's just frustrated by her
lack of power he's dynamic
yes the girl in the white is basically
course deleo
look at your face
uh yeah are you afraid of commitment
ryan yeah definitely at times yeah
there's been times
where one of us wants to proceed but
it doesn't happen but i think that it's
coming along
really well right now
[Music]
that's cute but hold
hold up what if it's the editing like
last time
that's permanent issues it's possible
but i'm just reacting to what i'm seeing
yeah of course you're going to be
reacting what you're saying after that
you have to dissect that you know but
it's possible
the editing yeah yeah because you know
they've been known to
cut [ __ ] out and and misplace reactions
yay but anyways let's keep watching when
are you going to introduce me to your
parents
gene and edward love me
when you date me
okay what what makes your relationship
that much different from
someone who says they're in a committed
relationship because someone won't
commit
i don't like to choose okay so this is
not a friends with benefits no they got
they got this is like
i want options and you can stay
committed to me
you're just waiting and hoping that's a
bad place to be yes
that's what happened she's blue shirt
she's waiting and hoping the other one
is not really engaged that's what's
going on and that's what the
the smile thing you know you know that
you know that you know that i'm
committed
that's why i said the smile meant
something and man something deeper than
that you know i mean
here's the thing right if you're dating
someone and they don't want the same
things you
leave don't sit there hoping or waiting
for them to change or be like if you
change the options always there
you don't want to be someone's option
plan b so that's my advice to anyone at
home who's watching
don't don't let yourself be that person
why would it be bad for us to be in a
committed relationship
it wouldn't i don't think it would be
bad
just not thinking i let those people
real you just call it first but yeah i
knew she was
i don't know something about it maybe
this guy's just not expressive he's got
a cold demeanor but
you know i don't know do you think it
would be i mean there's upsides and
downsides to everything
yeah why would it be bad for us to have
a committed relationship
it wouldn't be i don't think it would be
okay your turn
whoa whoa this is so uncomfortable
it is very one-sided relationship
one-sided relationship one-sided
relationship
one-sided
doesn't get it she doesn't get it from
the text she doesn't get it from a reply
she doesn't get it from her rejections
it's like it hurts to watch someone get
injected
and not learn but anyways i'm not ready
oh this is the next question
cool are you afraid of commitment yes
okay good why because it's the same
reason
i don't like to choose it's scary
i don't know i'm hyper type a and a
libra and i play through the what ifs
and there's just a lot of risk okay
do you love me
yes do you want me to be your boyfriend
would you want me to be your girlfriend
yeah let's do it did you just ask me out
we're in a relationship this kid's like
a
topic what am i watching i was the most
uncomfortable relationship ass do you
want to be my girlfriend
yeah you asking me out yeah let's do it
whoa that was really creepy to watch the
most enthusiasm he had during this whole
episode
is when he shouted out susie susie
could we still be friends if i started
dating someone uh
seriously i think so i could be friends
with you
i don't think you could be friends with
me if i started taking someone seriously
yeah no i couldn't why
use your words michaela i love you
and you know that oh that was awkward
yeah one's really in it the other one's
really not
okay here's what i'll say and i'll keep
it brief a lot of people are engaging in
friends with benefits but aren't
actually friends with benefits
while some people who are exploring the
options the other person is just hoping
to become the only option
that's really awkward to me i think you
have to make sure look
this is my thing if i'm doing that kind
of open scenario with somebody
i always want them to know where i stand
and i want to be cognizant of where they
stand not just based off what they say
but also how they feel because i said it
before you have to date compassionately
some people are not emotionally
responsible enough to make that smart
decision because they're hoping
for a delusional dream yeah you have
yeah you see
there's some people are gonna the open
relationship thing is very complicated
it's very complicated and at some point
you're gonna have to take steps for
the peop the person that is less
invested is gonna have to take steps
for the other one sometimes like either
break things off
or either because because the feelings
are going to be involved people are just
going to
get hurt so sometimes their want
for someone else in their life is going
to outweigh their respect for themselves
and if you love them you want them to
always be able to respect themselves and
to hold their values true to themselves
if i'm with a girl right and she doesn't
want kids but i really want them and for
me it's a must break deal
i'm going to break it off with her
because for me i'm unmovable on that
really important point
and i know she really doesn't want it
because for her like absolutely i'm not
going to hope that she's going to change
but if if she says yes in the hopes that
you're going to change
yeah no that's bad you're doing the
disservice to you yeah and to the other
person i know we live in this new age
where everyone wants to think that they
can be
you know really open and do a lot of
people are not cut out for and it's okay
but be honest with yourselves better to
be lonely and real with yourself than to
be fake and with someone who doesn't
really want you
that hurts and it's to hurt the longer
you stay in there and get more attached
or it doesn't want you the way you want
to be wanted rough i've taken from
experience i've sat in a relationship
that i shouldn't have
when i want some open and it hurt them
and it just
never sat well with me so since then i
just make the decision for both parties
if i know the other persons
because some people you know you know
you look at them in like feelings
they're hurt every time
you don't want to go out with them or
they find out you've been on another
yeah even though they agreed to it
they're hurt by it yeah i'm like i'm not
going to put you out of pain
so i know take it out take it out of the
misery
that's my advice to you guys if you guys
can do the open stuff just do it
compassionately and be considerate
and that's pretty much all i got well
it's a bit like what you said about the
crystalia stuff
yeah you have to start dating not just
for yourself you have to start dating
for
being conscious of what's going on yeah
that's about it yeah that's all i have
to say
a little parallel here if you haven't
seen the video go back and check it out
that's right
so if you guys enjoyed today's video
leave a comment all that good stuff we
want to hear your thoughts
[Music]
where's where's the weirdest place we've
had sex
we're both taking that work
[Applause]
they responded they responded they
responded but they cannot prove that
but yeah they responded you know the
manager comes in on monday in the season
they're like
you guys want to work overtime without
getting paid for overtime
yeah yeah scrub the grills
because i just assumed that they work at
a fast food joint
is that wrong no